there's undeniably a ton of drama this
season on The Bachelorette you're
welcome
Here I am but on Monday we got served
plenty of juicy scoop straight from
Jordan Rogers and Chad Johnson
themselves good guys at the end of the
day it's like half these guys are
cheating on their girlfriend passes them
broke up with girlfriends to go on the
show how can they be such good guys jo
Jo Fletcher gave Chad the boot last week
after the guys told her he was making
violent threats Chad who appeared on
Andy Cohen Sirius XM show insists he's
not as hot-headed as he seems people
think I'm just this violent crazy person
who like hurts women or something like
that right and the thing is like it's a
competition I'm gonna do what I have to
do I'm very nice for my girls and people
are just thinking that I'm you know
angry front runner Jordan Rogers weighed
in on Chad during another podcast
garbage time with Katie Nolan here's
what Jordan said about Chad in reference
to their SportsNation group date I just
don't think he grasped the scope of
things like that we're doing a fake
proposal everybody knows it's
embarrassing would that have been our
first choice absolutely not but you know
we're all we're all kind of having fun
on that date and I think there's it was
just a part of him that just I think
missed that aspect of it but yeah I mean
you can't you can't blame him for
sticking to his guns and speaking of
complicated relationships Jordan said
he's not exactly close with his older
brother Green Bay Packers quarterback
Aaron Rodgers I you know we have a
relationship the you know it's it's it's
complicated there's Aaron watching the
show do you know I'm sure everybody
watches this show oh yeah have you
talked to him about it at all I you know
I haven't got any pointers I'm like I
missing or am i dating